[Music]
Jessie J's romance with Channing Tatum
is definitely burning up the couple was
snapped holding hands and strolling
around London together on Thursday was a
month press both Channing and Jessie
kept a casual Channing and a baseball
cap jeans and sneakers Jessie in a sweat
suit jacket in sneakers and clearly they
couldn't stop smiling at each other
the pair has reportedly been dating
since last September but have recently
been more public earlier this month
Jessie shared this screenshot of a cute
message Channing Center on IG stories
and a source previously told e.t quote
this relationship is everything Jessie
has been searching for and she deserves
it Channing split from white Jenna Dewan
last April after nearly 10 years of
marriage our source previously said the
ex has remained on good terms though and
quote they want their relationship to
stay healthy for their daughter Everly
every kid is up doing like like the
proper suppon she's doing her own thing
Jenna has also moved on to Steve Ghazi
they also started dating last fall do
you want to talk about new love are you
happy I'm very because we love you so we
want you to be happy yes I'm very happy
thank you for us she's got the glow
ladies and gentlemen thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]